le site du festival des arts confinés a
ressurgi des méandres de la toile
une deuxième édition après celle du
printemps 2020 elle avait séduit cent
cinquante mille spectateurs en ligne
curieux de cet art du confinement en
train d'émerger ou photographes
plasticiens danseurs s'émancipe de leur
isolement en créant des pièces
originales
chaque soir à 19 heures le festival des
arts confiné offre de nouvelles
propositions artistiques et pour cette
deuxième édition
l'engouement des artistes pour ce lieu
d'exposition virtuelle se fait plus
discret on sent que ils ont déjà vécu un
confinement
on sent qu'ils sont un peu plus libres
qu'ils ont une autorisation d'aller
enregistrer d'aller créer d'aller
répéter
donc il ya il ya un petit peu moins de
présence des artistes
actuellement si nous étions précurseurs
au festival des arts confiné au banc à
la première édition
maintenant d'autres structures ont
installé leurs petits festivals même les
artistes d'ailleurs ont leur petit
festival personnel curateur du site
l'accordéoniste arnaud métivier a lui
même publié le morceau d'un album à
venir que les heureux souscripteurs
recevront à la mort de la reine
elizabeth
c'est peut-être dans dix ans dans 15 ans
dans 20 ans peut-être 50 ans qui sert je
le souhaite bien sûr longue vie à cette
cette dame que j'adore une artiste je
lui souhaite longue vie
j'ai plutôt voulu lui rendre hommage de
son vivant plutôt qu'une fois qu'elle
aurait disparu
insolite et éclectique ouvert aux
artistes du monde entier
le festival des arcs ont fini est une
plateforme qui déconfite résolument
notre vision de l'art on va être payé
pour la publicité